[Music]
you know the biggest challenge with
today's daily cancellation will be
convincing you that i'm not making any
of this up but it shouldn't take much
convincing because you ought to know by
now that it's impossible to invent a
form of leftist insanity that leftists
themselves have not already come up with
and even if i did dream up some new
brand of lunacy on my own we could still
be sure that some leftist somewhere has
already thought of it or will soon think
of it
and when they do think of it they will
take this thing that i said as a joke
and turn it into their mission and their
identity in life
with all that in mind we head over to uc
irvine and their women's center for
success
as their page on uc irvine's website
explains the women's center for success
quote advances gender equity by raising
consciousness on social justice concepts
fostering personal growth building
community connections encouraging
identity development and increasing
access to resources that support
holistic wellness
one important thing to note here is that
women's is spelled
w-o-m-x-n
now as you know the way to make things
inclusive uh it's been decided is to
stick a random x into the middle of them
x marks the woke as pirates used to say
obviously you know if you want to make a
word inclusive the best way to do that
is to arbitrarily change it so as to
make it unpronounceable that's how you
make it inclusive
but is there another more coherent
reason to spell women with an ex
well as aaron cebarium a reporter at the
washington free beacon pointed out on
twitter uc irvine has a whole page
dedicated to explaining the value of the
letter x and also grappling with the
challenges that it presents
their page with the heading why women
with an x explains the following quote
women is one of a few lexical and social
phenomena including the adoption of x in
naming gender non-conforming individuals
gender queer folks two spirit people
femmes transgender folks and non-binary
people
now please note that folks is spelled
f-o-l-x-s
so that it'd be properly pronounced i
guess foxes
we have to pronounce words like gollum
now in the name of inclusion so it
continues
women with an x acknowledges that gender
identity exists in a sphere and one word
has room for multiple gender expressions
without weighing one more important than
the other in addition it highlights that
more than one gender expression can be
impacted by patriarchy misogyny and
sexism this term recognizes that in the
past the history of feminism has
included racism transphobia and harmful
gender binary views
all of this is accomplished somehow with
the letter x
but is it as simple as that
can we just plop that x into the middle
of a word and then go about our day
peace with peace of mind
confident that everyone has been
included
well not so fast
because this actually real page on a
real website for a real college
university in the united states of
america in 2022 continues on for many
more paragraphs discussing the
importance and implication of the word x
when it's placed uh the letter x rather
when it's placed randomly into words for
no discernible reason
and then it gets to the caveats
and the exceptions of the potential
problems which are numerous
we're told this
it's important to note that not every
single person prefers to use the ex
identity is personal and is influenced
by lived experiences what matters most
is that we take into consideration each
person's own preferences and respect the
ways in which they choose to identify
they could be using the spelling with
the x or not and both preferences are
valid
okay so you see that
you can't just spell women with an ex
you must first conduct a survey of every
single person who might potentially read
the word that you're about to write and
find out if they prefer it
based on their lived experiences to have
the x or not have the x
but what happens if some preferred and
some don't prefer it
and what if some have other preferences
maybe there's a person whose lived
experience has led them to prefer the
that women is spelled with a z
in place of the x
maybe somebody's lived experience
demands that every letter in the word
women is replaced with a series of
random symbols and numbers
i for one am traumatized if women is not
spelled
wq33zl question mark 5 exclamation point
if i see it spelled any other way i'll
vomit and cry and
immediately stab the nearest person in
the throat
i can't be blamed for this
my lived experience is what it is
so does this mean that you
simply cannot spell the word or indeed
any word at all
as soon as the word exists in one form
spelled one way then it no longer
potentially exists in any other form
spelled any other way which makes it by
its nature non-inclusive
the only truly inclusive word is that
which is not written at all once it's
written it has taken on a certain form
and if it's in that form then it can't
be in any other form
so best then to avoid writing any words
but will that be enough
no it turns out
because even if words are not written
they're still spoken
and that too can be non-inclusive
so going back to this i must remind you
totally real page on a totally real
college's real website we are told this
quote
by being still new to the mainstream
there is not one particular
pronunciation of this word
most pronounce it like they are saying
women or woman
but spell the singular and plural with
the x
however
this raises the question if that
actually is truly inclusive
members of the blind community may be
left out if there's no audible way for
them to hear this distinction
others prefer to say it as weminx or
womanx or womux
these ways can bring attention to
whimxion when take when talking verbally
to someone about and opens up more
dialogue about linguistics
now um you might think that the one
advantage to being blind is that you're
spared this kind of thing
but the uber woke will not let the
visually impaired off the hook so easily
they too must be wrapped up in this
they must be given the experience of
hearing women pronounced
it wouldn't be fair if they were
deprived of the opportunity to hear
human beings speaking like your gps when
it's trying to pronounce a city with a
multi-syllabic name but this raises
questions
also
uh
what about deaf people
yes they can see the name but they're
not able to hear it being pronounced
and what about people who are both blind
and deaf
after all the work that helen keller did
how can we exclude members of her
community
what about those who are in a coma what
about members of the coma community
the fact is that you you can't write
this word or any word without excluding
people
and you can't speak the word or any word
without excluding people in truth you
cannot do say or think anything
without engaging in ruthless exclusion
just consider this
every time you do say or think anything
at all
you are excluding in that moment all of
the things you are not doing saying or
thinking and thus all of the people who
would prefer it if you were doing saying
or thinking all of the things that you
are not does that make sense
to simply exist and go about your day
and interact with the world
and communicate in any form
and certainly to develop your own unique
view of the world and opinion about
things is to exclude
worse it is to
discriminate it is to choose in every
moment one path instead of any other
exclusion and discrimination are
elemental inherent aspects of life on
planet earth
so then what should we do
well i think we have two options
either
we can stop obsessively trying to
include everybody all the time in
everything
and just go about our lives as normal
human beings
as human beings always have
or
in the name of inclusion we can all
launch ourselves collectively into space
um not in a rocket ship but individually
into space itself
where there is no sound no light no
gravity no oxygen
nothing at all but the formless
shapeless endless abyss
into which we can all tumble eternally
until we are consumed by it
and our bodies are ripped apart by the
vacuum
and we are all reduced to nothingness
only then
when we are all nothing
and nothing is everything and everything
is nothing
only then
will everyone truly be included
so that's option b and i think something
we should seriously consider for a
number of reasons
but until then uc irvine is today we
must say cancelled
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there
you